اتفاق ازعج الغرب مجددا تتسارع ردود الفعل
الممتعضه من قرار روسيا نشر اسلحه نوويه
على اراضي جارتها وحليفتها بيلاروسيا
الخبر اعلنه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الذي اكد استكمال بناء منشاه لتخزين
الاسلحه النوويه بحلول الاول من شهر يوليو
تموز المقبل نافيا في الوقت نفسه انتهاك
اتفاقيات عدم انتشار الاسلحه النوويه اما
اوكرانيا فتدعو لعقد اجتماع طارئ لمجلس
الامن لمناقشه خطه موسكو بنشر الاسلحه على
حدود الاتحاد الاوروبي تنتظر اوكرانيا
اجراءات فعاله من قبل المملكه المتحده
والصين والولايات المتحده وفرنسا لمواجهه
الابتزاز النووي الذي يمارسه الكرملين
نطالب بعقد اجتماع استثنائي وفوري لمجلس
الامن الدولي من اجل هذا الغرض
يمدد حلف شمال الاطلسي بالخطاب الروسي عن
نشر اسلحه نوويه في بيلاروسيا معتبرا بانه
خطير وغير مسؤول ويقول انه لم يرى اي
تغييرات في وضع روسيا النووي يدفعه لتعديل
وضعه النووي فيما حث مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفوريل
بيلاروسيا على عدم نشر اسلحه نوويه روسيه
على اراضيها استضافه بيلاروسيا لاسلحه
نوويه الروسيه سيعني تصعيدا غير مسؤول
وتهديدا للامن الاوروبي لا يزال بامكاني
بيلاروسيا ايقاف ذلك هذا خيارها الاتحاد
الاوروبي على استعداد للرد بفرض مزيد من
العقوبات
يقول المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي جون
كيربي ان الولايات المتحده لا تملك اي
مؤشر يدل على قيام روسيا بنقل اسلحه نوويه
حاليا الى بيلاروسيا